[Musique]
non non non
est-ce que vous pouvez tomber amoureux
amoureuse de premier rendez-vous
c'est vrai et moi je suis une amoureuse
de l'amour moi amoureuse de l'amour
vraiment premier rendez-vous tu te dis
voilà c'est l'homme de la vie mais moi
en fait alors je dis quand même beaucoup
de fois non avant d'aller voir quelqu'un
et donc quand je vais rencontrer
quelqu'un en général c'est que j'ai déjà
le coup de coeur qui est qui est présent
et quand je commence quelque chose à
quelqu'un je pense toujours que c'est la
mort de ma vie
quand j'y vais j'y vais quoi tu vois il
y en a il y en a un tous les six ans
on le renouvellement de l'épreuve sur un
encadrants
avec lui ce juin chaque soir et de
[Musique]
côté
nous pouvons pas encore là
[Applaudissements]